previously on Peugeot stuck hello
everybody my name is markiplier welcome
back the pogo stuck the first thing I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna get back to where
I was and I'm gonna do that right now no
god damn it no here we go it's still on
it's still on it's still it's still on
it's still on
oh yeah it's still on you better cut
that music off because I brought it back
oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna try this again yep yes yes
this is how I do this is how I do with
skill and patience anything is possible
and I'm back see that didn't take long
at all I think maybe this is gonna be
this is gonna be me turning it around
cuz I need to find the joy that's what I
need I need the joy god I have the joy
in your heart cuz if you don't all you
got is hate and what can you do with
hate nothing you can do nothing but hate
oh no oh no there I go okay alright
that's weird
no it's perfect
whoa ahh that was a fancy move I just
pulled I don't know if you guys could
tell that's a pretty fancy maneuver oh
no ok there's no recover in that ok well
I I literally like it's a 50-50
crapshoot of which way you turn when
you're gonna bounce I got him all wrong
ok I don't know why I second-guessed
myself on those all the time but I do oh
come on it's fine it's fine the only
reason I was able to get so far is
because I went at it Oh
no it's okay hahaha haha funny anecdote
funny joke buddy joke making fun of this
situation making light of it so no one
worries about me everyone should be
worried about me
perfectly threaded perfectly threaded
except somehow I'm able to be under that
when I'm done I don't know how that
works that's illogical haha man don't
you hate it when things are just so
illogical like that like of course it
should make sense that I'm you know if I
came in perfectly threading and I'd be
like it'd be clear above but there oh
here we go
again we I love this let's make you
funny make it God what no oh boy yep
there we go oh no no no no where am I
okay we're good we're good everything's
good okay alright at least it's better
than going all the way down which I
almost just did oh my god I don't know
what like there's so much branch for me
to hit and yet every time oh it's just
the very tip like no matter what I do I
just
I always operate on the tippy most tip
party I have so much room to work with
and yet I'm operating in the tiniest
fragment of a window why was that not
boost I went like fort 484 640
6720 please sir may I have some boost
please may I have some boost no no every
god damn it how how what what what what
even is happening what what happens
there that could not be more on the edge
that must have something to do with my
my stupid way of playing right for some
reason the way I play makes me do just
bear the slight Oh God
or I'm an idiot or I'm just a [ __ ]
idiot that's so on the edge why why do I
do that I'm not trying to get this with
the tiniest margin of error I'm not but
something about it something about the
way my brain works
what why was this so strong something
about the way my brain works makes me
only go for the route that has me in the
tiniest piece I mean good for me in
terms of like console' k oh I couldn't
[ __ ] see work I [ __ ] swear I swear
to [ __ ] I [ __ ] swear the [ __ ] duck I
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass in my family-friendly
bunghole nope God what was I thinking no
God I what what am i what am i doing
what am i doing wrong
what am i doing wrong in life that this
is how I'm treated you treat me this way
like I'm just garbage like I'm garbage
and I don't get it I know I don't get it
I'm a nice guy I pay my taxes I I'm
complicit in all my country's ills just
like everybody else and yet here I am
being thwarted by a video game then I
don't like
Wow how do I do that it's not just that
I fall down to the bottom it said I fall
down to the bottom within millimoles
like pixels away from anything that
would like touch me like I don't get
that I don't understand that God and
there I [ __ ] go god [ __ ] damn it
oh just touch it God all you had to do
with touch it you know how I am about
just the itty-bitty edges
give me the itty-bitty edge and I'll
give you an itty-bitty magic nope there
I go
[ __ ] ah ah [ __ ] are you
harmoniously kidding me [ __ ] off no god
dammit are you [ __ ] kidding no
[ __ ] give me off just let me touch it
god how can I be so [ __ ] bad God
don't stop you [ __ ] [ __ ] get away
from every time shut the [ __ ] up what
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] come on oh
my god I can't even [ __ ] believe this
[ __ ]
God are you kidding me
you know god I [ __ ] just are you I
saved that and you [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
kidding me no god damn it oh [ __ ] where
am I going god [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate
everything no God I just are you oh you
must be joking me you must you must be
joking this couldn't possibly be the
truth and I'm back hi honey I'm home
no God no no no no my god oh [ __ ] no no
no no no I don't understand what's
happening
you can't
no no oh no I didn't [ __ ] it I [ __ ] it
I saved it just a [ __ ] no I would
have been fine if I just hadn't saved it
at all I would have felt so much better
if I hadn't cuz then I wouldn't have
[ __ ] it no no no no God no god I did
it again I saved it just to [ __ ] it god
I save it just a [ __ ] oh come on okay
no god damn it why I'm okay with this
please for the love of God don't Oh
yep there I go there right [ __ ] oh my
god no no no no no no no no no [ __ ]
Christ
[Applause]
No why did I do that why would I do that
why would I do what I'm doing
why would I why did I just [ __ ] do
all of that every move there was stupid
why did I do that
that was terrible everything I did was
[ __ ] stupid no [ __ ] off with you know
that's no oh I knew that was gonna
happen I knew it cuz I've failed that
many that way many times I failed I
failed many many time failed many time
have I failed
no god damn it [ __ ] are you kidding
me
God did I hate so much I'm not okay if
you were wondering I'm not okay
but I don't need you babying me either
so don't even try don't be like new your
health [ __ ] my health
[ __ ] this game [ __ ] my health [ __ ] my
gremlin in my brain [ __ ] all of it
nothing else matters
but getting to the top of this [ __ ]
mountain if you know me you know me by
now and I ain't gonna give up on this
[ __ ]
no matter what at this point and now how
many times will mark hey apply a fall in
the same hole no no god what no [ __ ]
Christ
oh god damn I'm so sick of this [ __ ] why
would you let this game inside your home
why would you do that to yourself no I
have to make progress guys I have to
it's either I make progress or like I
give up the series cuz the episodes
can't have me not make progress I have
to make progress oh that was too far oh
my god I knew it was too far the one
saving grace about this game is that
it's fair it's not inconsistent it's not
unpredictable it is what it is which is
a giant steaming pile of garbage every
god [ __ ] time no that's too shallow
God not every [ __ ] time every I don't
get it why am i able to miss that by the
same margin every time shut the [ __ ] up
how how do I [ __ ] up this
same way every time I don't get it it's
always the same
finally I can't believe how long it took
me to get back that time I'm like the
opposite of a speed runner you know what
I mean
whereas a speedrun or practices like
precision doing things right
I practice precision in doing things
wrong oh god damn it no god dammit oh
[ __ ] off with that [ __ ] I just want
to play the game is just I just want to
play the game and I can't play the game
because it keeps kicking me back even
farther every time no oh my god yes here
I go
[ __ ] oh my god oh my god Oh
again again again a [ __ ] it's it's
every time this time it's I can get Oh
God it's every time I can get there so
consistently I can get there so
consistently and then I could do the
same [ __ ] happens to me as soon as I get
there shut the [ __ ] off stop what what
the [ __ ] what why did I have a boo-boo
boo-boo boo-boo
oh it's just tryin to kill me and hello
again I'm back welcome to the party me
no back up I'm still in this
nah nah [ __ ] there I go [ __ ] of
course yes
I'm back here again I have no idea how
this episode is gonna cut if it's gonna
be like a 15 [ __ ] minute
15:55 I don't care just I don't have
time to think about that right now
nailed it
I'm the best I would like to get one one
[ __ ] up from there without it sending me
all the way back down just one just one
I deserve one don't I [ __ ] it's every
time every time it does that it's not
fair now God every [ __ ] time every
time every time every time every time
it's the same [ __ ] up hey all right here
we go
no god damn no god damn it oh [ __ ] I had
god damnit Oh every time I get something
good going for me I [ __ ] it up
everything
no no no no no no no don't [ __ ] me don't
you [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I hate this
game so much no oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
turning it off forever God [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
no god damn it how many times have I
done this how many times good golly how
many times no God stop I literally can't
do anything else I can't end the episode
until I make progress oh come on No God
off for every wrong direction every
wrong [ __ ] da for every [ __ ] wrong
direction every wrong direction I didn't
make one there was like 20 [ __ ]
bounces I didn't make a one right
no god oh where am I going okay I'm back
in okay oh [ __ ] I just I'm completely
numb by the way just so you guys know if
you even care anymore I'm completely
[ __ ] numb I mean I'm not now I'm numb
to everything except deep-seated anger
at this point like I've got nothing left
inside me Oh God [ __ ] in there I go
okay here I am
oh god no here I go oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] off oh [ __ ] off there I go why was
that not a boost
I'll never [ __ ] know no God [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] me [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] everything
about it he's so stupid
I've been recording for two [ __ ]
hours on this one [ __ ] episode [ __ ] I
just want to make some goddamn progress
oh [ __ ] off god I'm so mad I just I
don't want to be angry anymore I don't
want to be angry anymore my hands hurt
my my neck hurts my back hurts my eyes
hurt no no no god [ __ ] damnit what Oh
God Oh where'd you come off [ __ ] off
no oh [ __ ] there I go god I know when
something's about to happen because I've
seen it so many times I've seen every
possible way that things can go wrong no
god damn it I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] no god damn
it oh [ __ ] me oh my god I am gonna lose
my mind I can't do this [ __ ] I'm so
frustrated I cannot explain I went from
like ahaha get angry whatever [ __ ] but
I'm just I've already reached despair I
just want to stop I just want to stop I
want to be able to stop but I can't now
there's a bunch of [ __ ] other people
here why
goddamnit what the [ __ ]
there we go no no no no no ah [ __ ] no
god damn it oh my god I'm so sick of
this I am so [ __ ] sick of this God
[ __ ] [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
God eight APRA corn oh my god just go oh
my god why are why did everyone come in
now and why do you all have guns so what
do you do here I'm not sure I know and
I've ruined it again
any chance of redemption I have at that
I [ __ ] up every time oh my god
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] there I go well I almost
add something there I almost had
something I just if I can get on that
pineapple
I can stop I can be free for now not of
the game forever because I'm gonna beat
it Ike it can't get any harder is the
thing about it it can't get any harder
there is no [ __ ] way that this [ __ ]
gets any harder because if it did then
no one would be able to do it and I know
people have done this no no no please
for the love of God no oh
[Music]
what what what what what the [ __ ] what
what what what stop oh my god what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is happening what the
[ __ ] my stuck it's stuck left I can't
fathom why I'm still doing this oh god I
was so close
alright I'll take this saving grace or
not god damn it
Oh little saving grace my ass little
saving grace my [ __ ] [ __ ]
god damn it just let me have that one
just let me have it like you you've
taken everything else for me why would
you not just let me have this one god
dammit god dammit god dammit god dammit
god [ __ ] dammit
I don't know why I can't get past that
part anymore I don't know why that part
I had under wraps and now I'm so nervous
every time I get there that I just [ __ ]
it up every time oh [ __ ] off really oh
my god
I can't [ __ ] believe this [ __ ] god
damn it I was right don't do this ah oh
my god oh my god oh my god I am gonna
lose my mind I am honestly gonna lose my
mind because this is unreal
this is unfathomable this is abominable
this is ridiculous I can't even come up
with the words and I'm being 100%
serious this is [ __ ] ridiculous
there's no way that this should be
taking me this long and cuz I know how
to beat it
I do the controls make sense they do and
I'm still [ __ ] losing my mind here I
just want to be done with this I want to
be done with this
I haven't eaten at all today I haven't
eaten it all today and it's [ __ ] like
five o'clock I just I can't keep don't
you [ __ ] dare God what was that what
the [ __ ] I don't know I don't know I
really don't [ __ ] know what that was
stops what stop why did you do that
god [ __ ] oh my god can you please
just oh my god oh my god don't duh
what the [ __ ] I just recovered and now
I'm not I don't understand [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can't keep doing this
this is absurd this is insanity this is
not fun
why oh [ __ ] off I am so done with this
[ __ ] I'm so done what three hours
three [ __ ] hours at this just to get
past one segment of this I [ __ ] hate
it so much
what no god damn it what the [ __ ]
happened what am i doing what did I just
do what the [ __ ] was that I don't know
but I got back so I guess I can't be
that upset I'm done I'm done I'm done
I'm done
holy [ __ ] oh my god oh my god oh my god
I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm
done I'm done I'm done I'm good I'm done
okay that's the end of this one three
hours and 10 minutes to get that far I
don't even know what to say
thank you well I want to thank the
Academy I I'm gonna get out of here
because my throat hurts I'm so hungry
I'm starving and I just need to do
anything except feel rage so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]
you